[Musique]
aussi sur le fondement de l'article de
49 alinéa 3 de la Constitution
j'engage la responsabilité de mon
gouvernement sur l'ensemble du projet de
loi de financement rectificatif de la
sécurité sociale pour 2023 modifier par
l'amendement de coordination
communiquée à l'Assemblée nationale
bienvenue dans ce nouvel épisode des
grands débats aujourd'hui retour sur une
séance qui restera sans doute dans
l'histoire de la législature nous sommes
le 16 mars 2023 Elisabeth borne
s'apprête à recourir à l'article 49-3 de
la Constitution après deux mois de
bataille parlementaires et d'opposition
dans la rue cet article lui permet de
faire adopter sa réforme des retraites
sans passer par le vote final des
députés la décision a été prise quelques
minutes seulement avant l'ouverture de
la séance de quoi déclencher les foudres
d'une partie de l'opposition regardez
la parole est à madame la Première
ministre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il y a un tel vacarme dans l'hémicycle
que la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale est obligée de suspendre par
deux fois la séance la séance reprend
dans un brouhaha toujours indescriptible
alors que sur les bancs de gauche on
continue à chanter en boucle la
Marseillaise
madame la présidente madame la
présidente de la commission des affaires
sociales madame la rapporteur général
Mesdames et Messieurs les rapporteurs
mesdames et messieurs les députés
en engageant la responsabilité de son
gouvernement le 15 novembre
1990 lors du débat sur la création de la
contribution sociale généralisée
Michel Rocard avait eu ses mots
dans un scrutin où chacun à votre es
selon sa conscience
permettez-moi de dire que je suis sûr
que ces dispositions réuniraient une
majorité peut-être même une large
majorité
c'est mon aujourd'hui je l'ai fait bien
et j'ajoute que si chacun votait selon
sa conscience et en cohérence avec ses
prises de position passée nous n'en
serions pas là cet après-midi
cet après-midi je n'ai pas envie de
revenir non plus sur le comportement de
ceux qui ont tout fait pour bloquer le
débat qui ont refusé d'échanger idée
contre idée programme contre programme
et ce sont contentés de multiplier les
insultes les excès et les attaques et
les cris au moment même où je m'exprime
dans son cul preuve supplémentaire
ce sont les mêmes qui n'ont cessé de
remettre en cause notre procédure
parlementaire nos institutions et donc
notre démocratie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
enfin cet après-midi je n'ai pas envie
de revenir sur le mutisme de ceux à
l'extrême droite de cette hémicycle qui
sont restés tapis de l'ombre tout au
long des débats qui ont préféré se taire
profitant en silence des outrances des
uns et des revirements des autres
mesdames et messieurs les députés ce que
je veux retenir de ces derniers mois
c'est que nous avons mené depuis
l'automne dernier avec le ministre du
Travail Olivier du socle une
concertation dense avec les
organisations syndicales patronales et
les groupes parlementaires ce que je
retiens de ces dernières semaines c'est
que nous nous sommes donnés les moyens
de la discussion et que vous avez passé
plus de temps de débats sur cette
réforme des retraites que sur chacune
des deux précédentes
ce que je retiens c'est l'engagement que
j'ai pris devant vous lors de ma
déclaration de politique générale et
lors de la présentation du projet du
gouvernement pour les retraites toujours
rechercher des compromis
le temps passé à dialoguer avec les
partenaires sociaux et les
parlementaires qui étaient attachés
comme nous à garantir l'avenir de notre
système de retraite par répartition nous
a permis de converger autour de
propositions nouvelles et d'une réforme
enrichie améliorée mais toujours
équilibré
hier la commission mixte paritaire
de la co-construction parlementaire
composé de députés et de sénateurs de
toutes les sensibilités et où les
soutiens du gouvernement ne sont pas
majoritaires à construire un compromis
ce compromis n'est pas le projet du
gouvernement c'est le texte du Parlement
ce compromis je n'en partageais pas tous
les points mais c'est le vôtre enrichi
de propositions de la majorité et des
oppositions des deux assemblées et
adopter au Sénat ce matin
et le texte du Parlement que contient-il
ça n'est pas un compromis tiède au
contraire ce sont des avancées pour
celles et ceux qui ont commencé à
travailler tôt pour celles et ceux qui
ont des métiers difficiles pour
revaloriser les pensions des femmes et
mieux prendre en compte leur carrière ou
encore pour augmenter les petites
pensions
mesdames et messieurs les députés
aujourd'hui sur le texte du Parlement
l'incertitude plane à quelques voies
près on ne peut pas prendre le risque de
voir 175 heures de débat parlementaire
s'effondrer on ne peut pas prendre le
risque de voir le compromis bâti par les
deux assemblées écartés on ne peut pas
faire de Paris sur l'avenir de nos
retraites cette réforme est nécessaire
[Applaudissements]
si parce que je suis attaché à notre
modèle social et parce que je crois dans
la démocratie parlementaire
c'est sur votre réforme sur le texte du
Parlement fruit d'un compromis entre les
deux assemblées que je suis prête à
engager ma responsabilité
aussi sur le fondement de l'article de
49 alinéa 3 de la Constitution
j'engage la responsabilité de mon
gouvernement sur l'ensemble du projet de
loi de financement rectificatif de la
sécurité sociale pour 2023 modifier par
l'amendement de coordination
communiquée à l'Assemblée nationale
dans quelques jours je n'en doute pas à
l'engagement de la responsabilité du
gouvernement répondront une ou plusieurs
notions de censure un vote aura donc
bien lieu comme il se doit et c'est donc
la démocratie parlementaire qui aura le
dernier mot
madame la première minute
que je suis
[Applaudissements]
Elisabeth borne n'était pas sûr d'avoir
le nombre de voix suffisantes pour faire
passer sa réforme la forme emblématique
du nouveau quinquennat d'Emmanuel Macron
décision a donc été prise d'engager la
responsabilité du gouvernement le
recours à l'article 49-3 sur un texte a
pour conséquence l'adoption de celui-ci
sauf si une motion de censure est
déposée dans les 24 heures qui suivent
c'est ce qui se produit le 20 mars deux
motions sont déposées la première portée
par le chevronné Charles de Courson
le groupe liotte a pris l'initiative de
cette notion de censure parce que nous
défendons plusieurs valeurs qui sont
attaquées par ce texte sur les retraites
nous défendons une nation française
décentralisée politiquement mais aussi
socialement nous défendons une société
solidaire qui aide chaque citoyen
trouver sa place une république sociale
telle qu'elle est inscrite dans notre
constitution nous défendons aussi une
société libre qui permet à chacun de
choisir sa vie y compris le moment de sa
retraite
au début de l'examen du projet de loi
sur les retraites nous avons parlé de
déni de démocratie depuis le
gouvernement a usé de toutes les
manœuvres possibles pour contourner et
contraindre le débat parlementaire pour
tordre des procédures nous avons déposé
cette notion de censure car vous avez
clairement détourné l'esprit de la
Constitution vous avez fait le choix
tout d'abord de recourir à cette fausse
loi de financement rectificatif de la
sécurité sociale dès janvier alors même
que la loi initiale était à peine votée
la note du Conseil d'État ne nous a pas
été transmise nous savons que certains
des articles du texte sont de véritables
cavaliers sociaux c'est le cas notamment
de l'index senior de disposition
relatives à la pénibilité ou à l'agirque
Arrco
ce que je dis ici n'est ni anecdotique
ni technique vous avez délibérément
choisi cette procédure pour préparer un
éventuel passage en force une procédure
qui facilite le recours à 11e 49-3 en un
an une procédure qui encadre et
contraint les délais d'examen rendant
impossible tout débat serein et
approfondi résultat l'Assemblée
nationale a examiné que deux articles
elle a d'ailleurs à une large majorité
rejetée d'articles 2 malgré tout
transmis au Sénat par le gouvernement
au Sénat justement vous avez fait le
choix de recourir au vote bloqué du 44.3
pour écourter les débats et tout cela
pour infini nous privé d'un vote sur le
texte issu de la CMP comment accepter un
tel mépris du Parlement comment accepter
de telles conditions d'examens sur un
texte qui aura des incidences durables
sur la vie de millions de nos
compatriotes alors qu'il fallait un vrai
dialogue avec les forces politiques et
les partenaires sociaux vous n'avez
proposé aux organisations syndicales
qu'un semblant de concertation ajoutant
au déni de démocratie politique indéni
de démocratie sociale
le président Macron après sa réélection
reconnaissait que je cite nombre de
Français avez voté pour lui non pour son
programme mais pour faire bourrage à
l'extrême droite et de nous promettre je
le cite j'ai conscience que ce vote
m'oblige pour les années à venir qui
est-il advenu de cette promesse monsieur
le président
qu'en est-il du fond de cette réforme
rappelons que ce projet de loi a été
vendu autour de deux arguments la
justice sociale et le financement
durable de notre système de retraite
votre premier argument ne tient pas vous
le savez au fond de vous le recul de
l'âge légal de 62 à 64 ans cristallise
en réalité tous tes injustices les 17,7
milliards d'euros d'économies attendus
sont essentiellement portés par les plus
modestes ils portent sur ceux qui auront
à travailler plus sans voir leur pension
progressées sur ceux qui ont commencé à
travailler tôt qui exercent souvent des
emplois pénibles précaires ceux qui ont
des carrières hachées et donc
principalement les femmes
ce sont toutes ces personnes qui ont été
peu reconnues lors de la crise sanitaire
et qui subissent maintenant l'inflation
de plein fouet cette réforme augmentera
la précarité de nos compatriotes qui
après 55 ans sont souvent hélas déjà
poussés vers la sortie le chômage ou le
RSA conscient des inégalités que vous
aggravez vous avez tenté d'atténuer
l'injustice de votre projet en
introduisant des mesures cache misères
mal calibrées quitte à aboutir à des
usines à gaz la promesse de pension
minimum à 1200 euros pour tous n'est
qu'une illusion voire un mensonge révélé
par l'obstination de plusieurs de nos
collègues à demander la vérité
après nous avoir dit qu'il n'avait aucun
compte à nous rendre le ministre a
reconnu que la mesure ne toucherait pas
200 000 bénéficiaires mais entre 10000
et 20 000 personnes chaque année
autre tour de passe-passe celle de fer
croire que nos concitoyens qui ont
commencé à travailler avant 21 ans de
cotiserait jamais plus de 43 ans tout
ceci est faux les conditions pour
bénéficier du dispositif carrière longue
sont bien plus complexes la réalité
c'est que dans deux tiers des cas ces
personnes devront cotiser plus de 43 à
nuités
j'en viens
j'en viens à présent à votre deuxième
argument le redressement des comptes de
la branche retraite avant tout je
rappellerai les insuffisantes de l'étude
d'impact qui ne permet pas de mesurer
les incidences exactes de cette réforme
l'insécurité budgétaire de ce texte doit
être souligné ainsi les 17,7 milliards
d'économies ne tiennent pas compte des
effets dus à l'accroissement des
dépenses sur l'assurance maladie le RSA
les allocations chômage l'invalidité que
les spécialistes estiment entre le tiers
et le quart des économies à réaliser et
à Lucie de l'accord trouvé en CMP les
dépenses supplémentaires s'élèvent à un
peu plus de 7 milliards tout cela mis
bout à bout il est permis de penser que
votre réforme ne pourrait finalement
aboutir qu'à un milliard d'économies par
an d'ici 2030
le rassemblement national de Marine Le
Pen a lui aussi déposé une motion de
censure la motion est portée par Laure
La Valette et lui du Var
sommes-nous là aujourd'hui le 20 mars
2023 prêt à censurer votre gouvernement
pour empêcher une réforme des retraites
dont personne ne veut pourquoi la
réponse est simple mais elle mérite
d'être rappelée parce que l'ego
gouvernemental n'a d'égal que la
contestation qu'il provoque contre lui
cette ego il a notamment conduit la
première ministre à utiliser 11 fois le
49-3 depuis juin dernier sans que la
brutalité ne s'efface au profit de la
lassitude madame la première minute vous
nous avez dit jeudi dernier en annonçant
votre onzième 49,3 sur cette réforme des
retraites je vous cite ce compromis
n'est pas le projet du gouvernement
c'est le texte du Parlement mais quel
culot quel culot madame la Première
ministre
mais madame la Première ministre il est
trop tard quel que soit l'issue de ce
vote ce jour vous aurez échoué échoué à
convaincre la représentation nationale
mais surtout échouée et c'est finalement
ça qui compte échouer à convaincre les
Français madame la première minute si
votre brutalité n'étonne plus personne
elle s'est accompagnée cette fois-ci
d'une propension au mensonges et au
contournement marqué et remarqué
jusqu'au bout et dans un cynisme absolu
vous avez tenté de dissimuler les
manquements de votre projet cynisme
quand le nombre réel de bénéficiaires de
la promesse d'une retraite minimale à
1200 euros et passer de 2 millions à
10000 cynisme lorsque Monsieur dussoft
ose dire à la représentation nationale
qui n'a aucun compte à lui rendre
foulant ainsi au pied notre Constitution
cynisme encore quand aucun ministre
n'adénien répond sur votre dispositif
carrière longue qui tire à pile ou face
la durée de cotisations de ceux qui ont
commencé tôt 43 ans 44 ans on ne
comprend pas mais bien loin du juste
prix c'est à la roue de l'infortune que
vous jouez mais rien de moins étonnant
gardez le silence et rester ambigu était
le seul moyen de tenter de vendre votre
réforme dont tout jusqu'à la
justification même de son existence et
bancale souvenez-vous elle devait être
inévitable
imposée par un prétendu déficit qui
menacerait notre système de retraite par
répartition et le conduirait à la
faillite cet argument d'autorité aurait
pu vous rendre la tâche bien facile mais
tous les économistes du Conseil
d'orientation des retraites lui-même et
parfois quelques membres dévoués du
gouvernement merci Monsieur Riester
l'ont désavoué notre projet pour les
retraites c'est clair et juste plus on a
commencé tôt plus on travaille dur et
donc plus on part tôt avec Marine Le Pen
un jeune ayant commencé avant 20 ans ne
cotisera pas plus de 40 à nuitée et pour
ainsi le souhaite bénéficier d'une
retraite bien méritée à partir de 60 ans
et pour ceux ayant commencé à partir
après 20 ans ce sera progressif sans
jamais dépasser 42 à nuités et 62
annuités et pas une année de plus notre
projet s'accompagne de mesure de bon
sens figurez-vous et qui aurait permis
de ne jamais voir cette réforme
maltraitante à l'ordre du jour
je parle bien sûr ici de productivité et
de natalité car oui mes chers collègues
oui ce ne sont pas des gros mots
ce ne sont pas des gros mots mais bien
les fondations d'un système de retraite
par répartition juste et efficace pour
une société du plein emploi qualitatif
et contre une société du plein emploi
ubérisé réindustrialisons le pays
produisons les richesses en France
donnons la priorité aux entreprises
françaises dans les marchés publics
supprimons la CFE qui pénalise les
entreprises locales baissons les impôts
de production qui nuisent à la
relocalisation pour une société qui
mesure la nécessité vitale d'une
natalité forte soutenant financièrement
les Français qui souhaitent agrandir
leur famille facilitons l'accès à la
propriété des jeunes couples et
institution une part fiscale pleine dès
le deuxième enfant le 21 mai 1850 lors
de son discours en faveur du suffrage
universel et contre un projet de loi
visant à l'empêcher victor Hugo a cette
tribune disait ces mots
cette loi est invalide cette loi est
nulle cette loi est morte avant même
d'être née et savez-vous s'il vous plaît
dans le pays de la franchise c'est
qu'elle est déloyale dans le premier
pays de l'honnêteté c'est qu'elle n'est
pas juste c'est qu'elle n'est pas vrai
c'est qu'elle cherche en vain à créer
une fausse justice et une fausse vérité
sociale de ces mots madame la
préministes je n'en effacerai pas un
seul au sujet de votre funeste réforme
nous voilà maintenant à quelques minutes
dans votre décision et je m'adresse à
vous chers collègues de tout bord votre
intégrité de parlementaire n'est-elle
pas heurtée par les marchandages en
provenance de l'Élysée comment
tolérez-vous la menace d'une dissolution
dès lors que le Président de la
République cherche à vous convaincre
acceptez-vous de participer ainsi au
délitement de notre démocratie sauf ceux
de mauvaise foi nous savons tous ici
qu'une motion de censure n'est pas un
programme commun pas plus qu'une volonté
de gouverner ensemble mais elle est
avant tout l'un des derniers moyens
constitutionnel de rejeter cette réforme
inutile et injuste dont l'immense
majorité des Français ne veut pas en
unissant nos voix nous exprimerions
uniquement la volonté du peuple de
France sur ce texte alors chiche
monsieur Macron allons à la dissolution
et demain nous reviendrons plus en
nombreux encore pour donner un gros plus
puissant voire majoritaire à Marine Le
Pen car plus que jamais je suis
convaincu que nous sommes la véritable
alternance convaincu qu'après vous ce
sera nous alors nous le disons haut et
fort à tous ceux qui nous font part de
leur sentiment d'un acharnement inhumain
de la part d'un gouvernement à la dérive
tenez bon tenez bon 2027 n'est plus si
loin
les deux motions de censure sont mises à
la discussion commune première à prendre
la parole Aurore berger la chef de fil
des députés Renaissance salut l'unité de
la majorité
d'abord je dois le dire et je le dis
s'il vous plaît au nom de mon groupe de
manière claire il y a ceux qui ont été
solides et cette solidité madame la
Première ministre c'est d'abord la vôtre
celle qui avait résisté avec courage et
avec dignité malgré les cris de cette
émission malgré l'impossibilité qui vous
était faite de parler vous vous êtes
exprimé de manière claire et vous avez
fait honneur à la vie politique et à la
vie démocratique de notre pays le
ministre du Travail que vous n'avez eu
de cesse d'invectiver d'insulter de
piétiner au sens figuré mais en vérité
finalement vous aviez envie de le faire
au sens propre oui Olivier du socle avec
Gabriel Attal on portait avec courage le
projet qui est aujourd'hui soumis à vos
votes ensuite
il y a cette notion de censure présentée
en grande partie par le groupe liotte
avec une diversité qui n'a de vous aura
pas échappé chers collègues dans la
composition de votre groupe mais je
parle à ceux qui dans votre groupe ont
défendu la réforme des retraites qui ont
défendu la candidature de François
Fillon qui disait allons-y allons à la
retraite à 65 ans et je pense notamment
à Charles de Courson puisque lui-même
avait assumé avec clarté cette campagne
et puis il y a le groupe les
républicains et en vérité la vérité nous
oblige à dire que oui oui nous avions un
compromis que nous avions bâti ensemble
oui parce que ça n'est pas un gros mot
dans la vie politique et démocratique
que d'établir du consensus et que
d'établir des compromis parce que c'est
la force même de notre assemblée que de
tout faire pour que des compromis
existent et ce compromis il a été
souhaité ardemment et voté il a été voté
au Sénat au Sénat la droite à la
majorité absolue et la droite a voté au
Sénat en commission mixte paritaire oui
cela a été voté par le président du
groupe Olivier Marleix enfin il y a
l'extrême droite je sais que vous
n'aimez pas ce terme mais c'est quand
même comme ça qu'on continue à vous
caractériser parce que c'est ce que vous
êtes au fond de vous c'est ce que sont
vos valeurs et finalement
finalement que dire sur le rassemblement
national en fait pousser un peu le mime
Marceau sa gesticule mais ça parle pas
parce qu'on vous demande de vous taire
la vérité elle est claire il y a un chef
une chef et seul elle a droit à la
parole les autres doivent d'abord se
taire et appuyer sur le bouton ou lever
la main quand on leur demande c'est ça
la triste vérité quelle rassemblement
national et puis enfin il y a face à moi
la majorité les trois groupes de la
majorité
Unis soudée responsable qui ont assumé
et qui assument jusqu'au bout leur
valeur leurs conviction et qui le font
sur le terrain tous les jours oui nous
le savons madame la Présidente
du courage mais ce courage la majorité
là en conclusion face aux extrêmes face
aux alliances de circonstances qu'on a
vu fleurir ces derniers jours face aux
opportunistes de tout bord face au
cynisme qui peut trop souvent exister
ici oui la réponse encore et toujours
elle est dans le dépassement et elle est
dans le rassemblement les Français nous
ont lu les Français nous ont choisis les
Français sont prêts au dépassement et au
rassemblement la majorité y est prête
que celles et ceux qui sont de bonnes
volonté s'engagent avec nous la
présidente du groupe la France insoumise
prend ensuite la parole elle veut
relayer la colère du peuple contre la
réforme des retraites elle rappelle
qu'une majorité de Français sont contre
cette réforme la parole est à Mathilde
de panneaux
tiens qui a trahi dans un mélange de
colère et de dégoût
la colère et le dégoût sont familiers
les Français l'ont éprouvé au lendemain
d'un dimanche de 2005 depuis ils ont
déserté les urnes ils sont retournés
parfois ils étaient déçus en 2017
résigné en mars 2022 ils vous ont
sanctionné en juin dernier et vous les
avez à nouveau trahis
en faisant comme si Emmanuel Macron
avait été élu sur son programme
trahi en gouvernant depuis 9 mois comme
si vous étiez majoritaire trahi avec un
misérable 49-3 pour faire passer une
réforme dont personne ne veut jamais un
président n'a voulu gouverner avec
autant d'aplombs par la colère et le
dégoût à présent deux Français sur trois
veulent que cette motion de s'enfuir
aboutisse pour faire chuter le
gouvernement et votre réforme
oui jeudi était le premier jour de la
fin du quinquennat d'Emmanuel Macron
vous n'avez aucune légitimité à faire
cette réforme et vous le savez votre
défaite est d'autant plus grande que
vous aviez mobilisé tout en Arsenal pour
l'imposer de force 50 jours pour
discuter d'un texte un temps de parole
limitée des petits accords de couloir
des ministres qui défilent pour parler
d'une réforme juste et équilibrée de
gauche et qui ne fera pas de perdant
d'autres qui accusent les grévistes de
provoquer une catastrophe écologique
agricole et sanitaire un vote bloqué au
Sénat un bras d'honneur à l'Assemblée
pour finir par un 49-3 sous forme
d'aveugle de faiblesse quelle misère
morale et politique ni légitimité
populaire ni légitimité parlementaire
vous avez précipité le pays dans une
crise de régime le 49-3 a fait l'effet
d'un détonateur
jeudi dernier des centaines de milliers
de gens dans tout le pays ce sont réunis
spontanément sidérés par votre brutalité
ils savent où réside la violence la
vraie pas dans des autocollants
placardés sur une permanence mais dans
le fait d'imposer deux enfermes de
briser d'user d'épuiser encore davantage
les corps et les nerfs comme à chaque
fois vous vous servez de la police pour
répondre le dégoût en quelques jours on
a vu poindre le spectre des gilets
jaunes dans le maintien du désordre
jeudi soir 97% des personnes
interpellées ont été relâchés 100
poursuite
1400 garde à vue prolongées inutilement
des jeunes manifestants humiliés à
Genouillé le dos au mur les mains sur la
tête des charges violentes et
injustifiées des nasses et fouilles
arbitraires vous tentez désespérément de
relancer la machine à découragement vous
n'y parviendrez pas
vous n'y parviendrez pas car la période
a révélé aux yeux de tous une réalité
insoutenable vous ne servez à rien peu
importe l'issue de cette motion de
censure vous avez déjà perdu
la réforme des retraites a reçu le
soutien d'ericsiotique mais à
l'Assemblée le groupe LR est divisé une
quinzaine de frondeurs refusent de
cautionner une réforme qui ne considère
comme injuste notamment pour ceux qui
ont commencé à travailler tout à la
tribune ces divisions sont éludées par
Olivier marlex président du groupe LR
nous assumons la nécessité d'une réforme
pour sauvegarder notre système de
retraite et défendre le pouvoir d'achat
des retraités le respect du travail
c'est aussi le droit à une retraite
décente après une vie de travail oui
nous assumons d'avoir tempéré cette
réforme 63 ans à la fin du quinquennat
plutôt que 65 ans oui nous assumons d'en
redistribuer tout de suite le bénéfice
pour 1,8 millions de retraités aux
carrières complètes mais aux pensions
les plus modestes pour leur permettre
d'avoir 670 euros de plus en moyenne
chaque année non nous ne nous
associerons pas à ceux qui ont pour
funeste slogan tout cramé ou révolution
nous ne ventrons donc pas l'émotion de
censure
nous ne nous laisserons pas entraîner
par une extrême gauche qui est assume de
vouloir détruire les institutions de la
Cinquième République nous ne serons pas
les témoins de ces noces barbares entre
ceux qui assument vouloir mettre le
chaos et ceux qui silencieux n'ont
aucune proposition pour sauver les
retraites mais espère tirer profit de ce
chaos
soyons clairs le problème aujourd'hui ce
n'est pas la réforme des retraites seul
président de la République
nous regrettons cette méthode qui
confond volonté politique et absence de
dialogue social réel et sincère avec les
partenaires sociaux une méthode qui
laisse place un temps de revirement et
d'un cohérence ne vous étonnez pas que
des Français n'adhèrent pas à votre
réforme puisque le président Macron
lui-même il y a trois ans la critiquait
avec virulence la France a besoin
d'unité nationale
mais vous n'en êtes pas le chemin vous
n'êtes que celui de la facilité
le président de la République
entre les mains de nombreux outils
constitutionnels
il peut changer de gouvernement
il peut recourir au référendum il peut
dissoudre
[Musique]
soyons clairs il n'y a aucune offre de
notre part juste une demande le voir
exercer différemment son mandat à lui
d'entendre les avertissements y compris
le nôtre s'il veut aller au bout de son
quinquennat réformer oui fracturé non
les orateurs des différents groupes
politiques se succèdent à la tribune
pour donner leur position de vote chacun
ses arguments sa philosophie générale
sur la réforme
notre premier regret celui d'avoir
jamais pu pleinement examiner et voter
ce texte en première lecture alors que
les deux semaines prévues suffisait à le
faire chers collègues de l'opposition en
dépit des règles de fair-play
parlementaire et plus encore de toute
vertu démocratique vous avez décidé de
détourner notre règlement pour créer une
embolie parlementaire motion
prise de parole identique à répétition
comportement empreint d'une forte
violence symbolique rappelle au
règlement et surtout plus de 20 000
amendements vous avez fait feu de tout
bois pour empêcher la tenue de nos
débats notre second regret et le manque
de responsabilité de certaines
oppositions je ne parle pas de celles
qui n'avait pas de projet si ce n'est de
se cacher derrière une forme de
respectabilité pour déposer à la fin une
motion de censure en espérant que
personne ne remarquerait leur absence de
propositions je ne parle pas non plus de
ceux qui ont défendu et voté en son
temps 2013 une réforme qui amenait les
Français à dépasser de plus d'un an
l'âge légal de 62 ans sans le dire
honnêtement et qui défendent aujourd'hui
des propositions totalement illusoires
se raccrochant 60 ans croyant retrouver
par ce totem les grandeurs de 1981 et
oubliant les grades difficultés qui ont
suivi cette parenthèse enchantée
nous voulions très majoritairement
groupe démocrate modem et indépendant
aller au vote de ce texte après
peut-être pour certaines et certains des
doutes mais surtout avec la conviction
que cette loi a été nécessaire et utile
nous prenons acte de la décision qui a
été prise de déclencher la procédure
prévue par la Linéa 3 de l'article 49 de
notre Constitution cet outil existe il
permet aux forces politiques qui sont
contre ce texte de le rejeter si elles
sont majoritaires
alors le groupe démocrate prend acte
[Musique]
de cette inconscience acte de l'esprit
de responsabilité de responsabilité qui
anime le gouvernement et vous l'aurez
compris bien sûr soutenant le
gouvernement et persuadé de la nécessité
d'une réforme pour pérenniser notre
système de retraite nous nous voterons
pas cette censure mais il y aura un
après et de toute crise nous devons
tirer des leçons réfléchir au fond et à
la méthode ce que nous souhaitons
profondément au groupe démocrate modem
et indépendant je vous remercie quoi
qu'il en coûte à la démocratie la
réforme des retraites voulues par le
Président de la République est un coup
de force politique elle n'est pas
seulement un impôt sur la vie de celles
et de ceux qui n'ont que leur force de
travail pour vivre elle symbolise comme
jamais sa pratique solitaire du pouvoir
qui pervertit la démocratie rend
possible sans retournement en son
contraire impose ces volontés sans
discussion avec arrogance et mépris
mépris du débat parlementaire et du
dialogue social
mépris de la mobilisation syndicale et
de la volonté populaire mépris de
l'opposition majoritaire dès lors que
comme vous l'avez concédé vous-même le
compte n'est pas mépris de
l'intelligence des citoyens quant à leur
propre avenir mépris de l'exigence du
transparence de sincérité et de vérité
derrière aux éléments de langage d'une
réforme de progrès social derrière
l'autre cudence d'un ministre du Travail
capable de la prétendre de gauche mais
celui-là à tout oublié vous engagez à
marche forcée la précarisation des
seniors qui seront demain plus nombreux
au RSA à la SS et au chômage vous taisez
derrière ce projet soi-disant juste et
équitable que 60% des économies se
feront sur le dos des femmes déjà
grandes perdantes de notre modèle
économique
ces mêmes femmes qui occupent en grande
partie des métiers pénibles les métiers
du lien que vous qualifiez hier
d’essentiel et que vous brisez
aujourd'hui au détriment des besoins
d'une société vieillissante et
vulnérable
madame la Première ministre votre
réforme est percluse de fausses
promesses et de vraiment songe vous
trouverez format juste et brutal n'a pas
de majorité elle n'a pas de majorité
dans le pays elle est la contre elle
toutes les organisations syndicales plus
des trois quarts de nos compatriotes la
rejette votre réforme n'a pas de
majorité dans cette assemblée retirez-la
ou si vous mettez là au suffrage des
Françaises et des Français et si vous ne
le faites pas nous le ferons à travers
un référendum d'initiative partagé
donnant la parole à celles et à ceux à
qui vous la refusez
quoi qu'il en coûte à la démocratie le
président se comporte aujourd'hui en
forcené en acharné en former désormais
dans un tête-à-tête avec lui-même ce
n'est pas du courage c'est de l'art et
des raisons retirer cette réforme il en
coûtera moins que votre obstination car
il en va désormais de l'intérêt général
de la concorde civile de l'avenir de
notre démocratie et quand tout s'écroule
je vous l'assure pour tenir debout il
faut bien plus qu'une paire de bottes
des députés socialistes et apparentés
voteront cette motion de censure
transpartisane et j'invite chacune et
chacun d'entre vous à la voté car elle
est un acte de foi dans une démocratie
parlementaire à laquelle le gouvernement
et le président en définitive ne croit
plus
le président de la République a fermé il
y a quelques années qu'il fallait aussi
les entre humilité et arrogance et que
si vous tombiez d'un côté vous deveniez
soit inefficace soit dangereux pour
réussissez dans cette réforme à devenir
les deux quoi qu'il en coûte pour la
démocratie
je vous remercie
nous sommes à un moment particulièrement
grave notre histoire commune sans
grandiloquence il faut ses émotions je
crois pouvoir dire que notre pays
traverse une crise de confiance sérieuse
dont le climat dans notre assemblée
témoigne clairement
cet après-midi chacun de nous devra
faire un choix en responsabilité voter
cette motion de censure c'est faire
tomber le gouvernement et ainsi rajouter
du désordre au chaos chacun des membres
de la représentation nationale
s'exprimera en son âme et conscience je
vous rassure personne je dis bien
personne ne se réjouit du recours à cet
article 49 alinéa 3 parmi les
parlementaires ici présents qui sont
tout aussi attachés que vous à la
préservation des prérogatifs du
Parlement mais dire que cela constitue
un déni de démocratie ou une atteinte au
droit du Parlement après 175 heures de
débat est quasiment autant d'obstruction
nous ne pouvons pas l'entendre une
réforme de retraite est toujours une
réforme difficile mes chers collègues
ici menées dans un contexte délicat que
personne n'ignore
mais ça n'en est pas moins une réforme
nécessaire nous sommes confrontés à une
réalité démographique implacable et nous
devons travailler plus longtemps pour
pouvoir y faire face c'est un choix de
société celui de ne pas augmenter les
cotisations sociales ou de baisser les
pensions même choix qu'on fait tous nos
voisins européens ce que nous proposons
c'est une meilleure prise en compte des
situations des familles une meilleure
prise en compte des carrières des femmes
une meilleure prise en compte des
carrières longues la valorisation de
l'engagement des sapeurs-pompiers
volontaires et des élus locaux et ce ne
sont là que quelques exemples ce texte
ne prétend pas bien sûr gommer toutes
les injustices qui existent elles sont
nombreuses mais il y contribue en
dédiant 7 milliards d'euros à leur
réparation ce qui n'est pas négligeable
et c'est même plus d'un tiers des
économies générées
mes chers collègues nous avons devant
nous deux motions l'une d'opportunités
et l'autre partisane les deux peuvent
déstabiliser notre système démocratique
surtout les deux nuiront au système de
retraite et à sa pérennité car elles
auront pour conséquence de pousser à
l'emprunt illimité sur les marchés
financiers dont certains disent pourtant
vouloir s'émanciper notre mandat électif
nous oblige vis-à-vis des Français la
première de ces obligations c'est agir
en responsabilité et d'être responsable
en ce jour c'est rappeler qu'un pays
surendetté ne peut pas financer son
avenir prétendre l'inverse c'est
notamment mentir à notre jeunesse qui
aura assumé les conséquences de nos
choix par le vote de ces notions de
censure vous légitimez le comportement
des députés qui brandissent des
pancartes dans cette hémicycle eu le
gouvernement comme dans un stade couvre
la voie de la première ministre où font
encore mine de découvrir le
fonctionnement d'une commission mixte
paritaire à la fin de nos débats une
chose est certaine toutefois notre
assemblée si ce n'est l'ensemble de nos
institution et notre démocraties ne
sortiront pas indemne de cette séquence
les torts sont partagés des erreurs ont
été commises de parts et d'autres nous
devons nous livrer à une introspection
approfondie sur l'ensemble de ces bancs
sans exception je le répète cette
réforme est nécessaire et l'inaction est
un luxe que nous nous pouvons pas nous
payer plus nous payer vous l'aurez
compris nous avons besoin d'un CAP qui
permet à tous de se projeter dans un
futur serein et ambitieux je sais que
nous pourrons compter sur votre
engagement plein et entier madame la
Première ministre pour y parvenir c'est
pour cette raison que les députés du
groupe horizon et apparentés ne voteront
pas ces deux notions de censure jeudi 16
mars 2023 constitue un point de rupture
la rupture entre un président et tout un
peuple
sa rupture entre un président de la
République qui a théorisé la société des
premiers de cordée et tout un peuple qui
depuis qu'il a fait la Révolution en
1789 recherche constamment obstinément
passionnément la réalisation de la
promesse républicaine de l'égalité c'est
au nom de l'égalité que les Français se
lèvent contre votre réforme ne l'ignorez
pas ne le méprisez pas ne méprisez pas
ces millions de personnes qui ont défilé
et qui défileront demain encore
soutenues par tout un pays ne fermez pas
les yeux à la vue des pancartes qui
fleurissent un peu partout en France et
qui tombe bien que mal quand de vous
faire entendre raison alors pendant
quelques instants je vais me faire le
porte-voix de ce que vous avez décidé
d'ignorer il chante avec Macron liberté
égalité retraite mais quand vous serez
décédé il chante encore les précaires
prêtres précaires ce n'est pas un métier
ou encore les profits des milliardaires
pour les vieux jours de nos grands-mères
la voici enfin la vérité notre système
de n'est pas en danger ni aujourd'hui ni
demain non vous voulez faire 18
milliards d'euros d'économies sur le dos
des 55 65 ans pour diminuer aveuglément
les dépenses publiques au risque de
mettre à genoux notre économie nos
démocraties et nos modèles sociaux ce
que vous présentez n'est pas une réforme
c'est une aberration une injustice faite
aux femmes une injustice faite au
travailleur de plus de 55 ans qui sont
relégués aux marges du marché du travail
une injustice faite aux travailleuses
des métiers pénibles qui malgré la
dureté de leur travail devont travailler
jusqu'à 64 ans une injustice fait au
travailleur qui triment avant même
d'être pleinement entrée dans l'âge
adulte derrière les carrières longues il
y a des vies passées à les gagner alors
oui c'est l'honneur de la représentation
nationale d'avoir débusqué vos mensonges
c'est l'honneur de la représentation
nationale d'avoir refusé d'être
instrumentalisé par un président de la
République qui oppose démocratie
politique et démocratie sociale c'est
l'honneur de la représentation nationale
d'avoir su entendre le syndical afro
exceptionnel un front historique que je
salue depuis cette assemblée la CFDT la
CGT est faux cfe-cgt la fftc l'une ça
solidaire la FSU lunaire Lafage la
fidèle voilicienne et le mouvement
national lycéen se front syndical nous
oblige prenons garde prenez garde la
démocratie sociale n'est pas quantité
négligeable en démocratie elle est notre
lien indispensable au monde du travail
aux travailleurs c'est-à-dire aux
Français un lien aujourd'hui qui menace
d'être brisé enfin c'est l'honneur de la
représentation nationale d'avoir trouvé
le chemin d'une Concorde derrière le
groupe liotte que je salue d'ailleurs
pour exprimer le rejet de cette réforme
injuste et d'une méthode brutale
vous avez plongé la France dans une
prise politique profonde transformée une
crise sociale en une crise de régime
vous n'avez plus les moyens de gouverner
un pays qui a pourtant besoin d'engager
des réformes structurelles pour
affronter la crise climatique
environnementale vous n'avez plus les
moyens de gouverner un pays qui est
rongé par la défiance depuis la gilets
jaunes vous n'avez plus les moyens de
gouverner un pays où les températures
augmentent et où les pluies ne sont plus
ou demain les travailleurs du BTP
travailleront sur les toits sous 50
degrés au soleil vous n'avez plus les
moyens de gouverner un pays qui
s'enfonce dans une spirale
inflationniste et qui fracasse les plus
vulnérables c'est pourquoi madame la
Première ministre les écologistes
voteront sans la moindre hésitation
cette notion de censure nous ne pouvons
pas nous permettre un gouvernement sans
légitimité qui n'aura pas les moyens
d'agir
une colère
pas un coup de colère
encore moins une vague de désapprobation
une profondeur
quelque chose dans l'ordre de la révolte
même le refus sans appel de la
régression sociale le refus de se voir
voler d'eau de ses meilleures années de
retraite le sentiment de ne jamais
pouvoir être entendu le sentiment d'être
pris pour des imbéciles le sentiment de
ne pas être respecté l'idée que ça
suffit tout simplement je ne veux même
plus vous redire à quel point votre
projet est scandaleux injuste
injustifiable inégalitaire régressif
attentats au monde du travail et douce
heureux pour le monde de la finance vous
pouvez toujours pointer les
responsabilités des autres la vôtre est
écrasante nous avons entendu les petites
manipulations pour se rattraper ou
branches cette notion tiendrait lieu de
vote sur le texte ce vote vous en avez
privé notre assemblée parce que vous
alliez le perdre vous avez perdu cette
notion renverrait ce texte d'où il
n'aurait jamais dû sortir mais désormais
la question va au-delà la gravité de la
situation provoqué par vos choix vous
placent dans l'incapacité de continuer à
conduire la politique de la nation chers
et chers collègues par-delà les mesures
elles-mêmes chacune et chacun sait bien
ici que ça ne peut pas continuer comme
ça ne vous racontez pas d'histoire ne
cherchez pas d'excuses ou de
justification libérons ce gouvernement
de ses responsabilités c'est notre
responsabilité de parlementaire c'est
notre responsabilité de lui demander de
partir avec sa réforme sous le bras les
mobilisations populaires dans notre pays
ont provoqué conquis accompagner les
plus belles avancées sociales et
démocratiques notre assemblée doit
trouver des issues tracer des
perspectives et il faut pour cela
produire des gestes quel gestes
d'apaisement de respect de compréhension
ont été produits par l'exécutif ces
derniers jours aucun le sens de notre
motion est clair elle veut porter
l'espoir d'améliorer le droit à la
retraite pas de le réduire elle veut
porter l'espoir d'une alternative
politique heureuse elle veut battre en
brèche les projets dangereux
égalitaire anti fraternelle de l'extrême
droite qui est sans solution pour nos
retraites notre motion veut mettre un
grand coup de frein à la frénésie des
politiques libérales et de la loi de
l'argent elle appelle à mettre à l'ordre
du jour les belles choses qui sont dans
les têtes et dans les cœurs et si le
vote de cette motion devait décevoir
nous disposons encore d'outils pour nous
faire entendre nous avons déposé un
recours et une proposition de référendum
d'initiative partagée qui devrait être
validées pour montrer que nos
institutions ne sont pas complètement
inopérantes face à une telle crise
démocratique alors nous irons partout
débattre et chercher les signatures par
millions pour imposer une sanction
démocratique à cette réforme
la bataille se poursuit dans les
mobilisations sociales et notamment avec
cette grande journée de jeudi prochain
c'est contre cette réforme
pour que vive le droit à la retraite
pour le respect de la volonté populaire
pour sortir de la crise au nom de la
République que les députés communistes
et ultramarins de la Gauche démocrate et
républicaine sont actrices et acteurs
d'une motion de censure
si je vous remercie mon cher collègue
[Applaudissements]
voilà donc pour les positions de vote de
chacun des groupes politiques de
l'Assemblée nationale Elizabeth borne
reprend la parole dans une ambiance un
peu plus calme et un hémicycle un peu
plus vide
des champs des hurlements des invectives
des pupitres qui claquent voilà le
spectacle auquel ce sont livrés jeudi
dernier certains députés
dans un déchaînement de violence comme
cette émission en a peu connu sous la
Cinquième République
certains élus de la nation ont une
nouvelle fois montré le peu de cas qu'il
faisait du débat du Parlement de la
démocratie
ce n'était pas un fait isolé
c'était le paroxysme de semaine entière
durant lesquels au cœur même du
Parlement nous avons vu l'anti
parlementarisme à l'oeuvre sous toutes
ses facettes
mesdames et messieurs les députés cet
après-midi intervention après
intervention j'ai constaté en écoutant
certains orateurs qu'il n'y a décidément
pas de limite à la duplicité
ce sont les mêmes qui ont tout fait pour
saboter le débat à coup d'amendement
dilatoire de cris et d'insultes qui
viennent nous reprocher de ne pas avoir
pu suffisamment débattre
la haine et la brutalité ne devrait pas
avoir leur place dans le débat
parlementaire car si l'on ne peut plus
débattre à l'Assemblée nationale c'est
le fonctionnement même de notre
démocratie qui est empêché
mais alors il faut être clair sur les
alternatives certaines ont été
présentées par des amendements dans
cette émission elles peuvent se résumer
en deux mots matraquage fiscal ce sont
des impôts et des charges
supplémentaires
qui pèseraient sur le pouvoir d'achat
des Français et menacerait leurs emplois
l'autre chemin que certains proposent
c'est l'allongement de la durée de
cotisation
mais alors il faut dire la vérité aux
Français pour équilibrer notre système
de retraite par répartition il nous
faudrait travailler 45 années en
transparence que ceux qui la proposent
où l'on proposait assume les
conséquences d'une telle mesure mesdames
et messieurs les députés avec cette
réforme nous ne sommes jamais allés
aussi loin dans la construction d'un
compromis
[Applaudissements]
le gouvernement a pris toutes ses
responsabilités
mais les aventures individuelles les
positionnements tactiques et la crainte
de l'impopularité n'ont pas permis
d'assurer une majorité
cependant comme il se doit la démocratie
parlementaire aura le dernier mot c'est
elle qui a permis de forger ce texte de
l'améliorer de l'enrichir par des
propositions de l'Assemblée nationale
comme du Sénat des propositions de la
majorité comme des oppositions c'est la
démocratie parlementaire qui a permis
d'adopter ce texte par deux fois au
Sénat et lors d'une commission mixte
paritaire où le gouvernement n'était pas
présent et ses soutiens n'étaient pas
majoritaires
c'est enfin la démocratie parlementaire
qui s'exprimera par votre
nos 49,3 n'est pas l'invention d'un
dictateur mais le choix profondément
démocrate qu'a fait le général de Gaulle
et qui a approuvé le peuple français
car à la fin il y a un vote nous sommes
au terme du cheminement démocratique et
politique de cette réforme si vous
voulez renverser le gouvernement qui la
porte vous en avez désormais la
possibilité je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
lors du vote d'une motion de censure
seuls les voies pour compte c'est-à-dire
que les députés qui ne prennent pas par
vote ou ceux qui s'abstiennent sont
considérés comme soutenant le
gouvernement alors voyons tout de suite
le résultat du scrutin
voici le résultat du scrutin majorité
requise pour l'adoption de la motion de
censure soit la majorité absolue des
membres composants cette assemblée 297
pour l'adoption 278 la majorité requise
n'étant pas atteinte la motion de
censure n'est pas adoptée je vais mettre
maintenant en voile la motion de censure
déposée par Madame Marine Le Pen et 87
membres de l'Assemblée le scrutin est
annoncé dans l'enceinte de l'Assemblée
nationale voici le résultat du scrutin
majorité requise pour l'adoption de la
motion de censure sur la majorité
absolue des membres composant
l'assemblée 287 pour l'adoption 94 la
majorité requise n'étant pas atteinte la
motion de censure n'est pas adoptée
aucune des deux motions de censure
déposées n'ayant été adoptée le projet
de loi de financement rectificatif de la
sécurité sociale pour 2023 compte tenu
du texte de la commission mixte
paritaire modifiée par l'amendement
déposé par le Gouvernement et considéré
comme adopté
à neuf ou après les oppositions ont donc
échoué à renverser le gouvernement après
la décision de recourir aux 49-3 des
violences éclateront dans certaines
manifestations un peu partout en France
la réforme sera promulguée le 14 avril
2023 un système ce numéro des grands
débats à très bientôt sur LCP
[Musique]